hi this is mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming through with another
math video to help you boost your score
in your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math
less stressful and more enjoyable so
let's get right into this video today
we're going to talk about in this video
is how to do unit conversions so whether
you're in a science class a math class
any type of class what you're going to
be doing these unit conversions and it's
good to know how to do them effectively
efficiently and accurately so first
thing we want to talk about are just
some of the different ways to understand
the units and these come up over and
over again so these are some little ways
of remembering I'll just go through this
real quick with you so this symbol here
is like g 4 gallons okay and inside of
one gallon you can see that there's four
quarts okay that's what the Q's
represent so four chords inside of the
courts you can see you can fit two peas
which are the pints and inside of the
pipes you can fit two little cups right
so two cups inside each pint but if you
wanted to find out like how many cups in
a gallon you can then add all these up
and you can see that there are 16 cups
in a gallon so having a little ways to
remember that like like this here is a
good is a good thing to have so another
one we have is this metric system here
the kilometers and hectometers and deca
meters and so on what some students will
remember is this acronym King Henry
doesn't usually drink chocolate milk so
it's kind of funny way of remembering it
but basically the U stands for the unit
so it could be meters liters grams like
that but then it has a prefix like
decimeters centimeters millimeters like
that or deca meters hectometers you know
kilometers kilometers right but every
time you move from one unit to the next
unit when you're going to the left it's
getting larger by ten hundred thousand
when you go to the right it's getting
smaller by ten hundred thousand so it's
like moving the decimal place you know
one place each time you move to the
right or the left and we'll take a look
at that in some of the examples and then
some other simple ones are like one mile
is 5,280 feet and one pound is 16 ounces
and so on and so forth so some of these
common ones you're going to want to
memorize let's get right into the unit
versions now so how do you convert from
12 feet per second two miles per hour
it's a good question right so let's see
so first thing we want to do is want to
get from feet to miles okay so let's see
so basically what we have here is we
have 5280 feet for every one mile now
the question is is where do we put the
feet and where do we put the miles what
you want to do is you want to make sure
that the feet which are the units that
you don't want are going to cancel
numerator and denominator so you don't
want the feet both in the numerator you
want one of the numerator one of the
dynamic so they're going to cancel each
other out and that's equal to one mile
ok now we want to get rid of the seconds
we want to convert from seconds to hours
now you might want to convert from
seconds to minutes first and then
minutes to hours so let's do it like
that so what we have is there's 60
seconds for every one minute and the
reason I set it up this way and not the
reciprocal way is because i want the
seconds to cancel with a second
numerator and denominator then for every
minute i'm sorry for every 60 minutes
there's one hour so you can see again
numerator and denominator canceling now
you know your you've got it right
because at the very end you can see that
we have miles of the numerator see miles
hours in the denominator and that's
miles per hour miles / hours so all it's
left to do now is multiply all the
numerators together all the denominators
together and then divide and you've got
the number of miles per hour so let's go
to the next example the next example
we've got eight gallons per three
minutes we want to convert it into
quarts per hour okay so that's why I
mentioned this at the very beginning so
let's see so how many quarts in a gallon
it looks like 1 2 3 4 q's four quarts
inside of one gallon so let's go ahead
and multiply by for every one gallon one
GL there's four quarts and again you can
see the gallons are going to cancel a
numerator and denominator now i want to
go from minutes to hours okay so we know
there's 60 minutes in an hour
so the minutes are canceling numerator
and denominator you can see the only
units that we're left with our courts /
our courts in the numerator hours in the
denominator all we have to do is
multiply all the numerators together
multiply all the denominators together
and simplify so here let's see if we can
do this one this is 4 times 6 is 24
right well let's see that we can do this
another way so we've got 8 times 6 is
4890 6 192 add the 0 / 3 and if you take
that and divide you're going to get the
number of quarts per hour so let's go to
the next one we've got eight centimeters
per one minute we want to convert two
meters per day right so centimeters to
meters okay that's what we were talking
about here earlier this King Henry
doesn't usually drink chocolate milk
right so what you can see here is that
centimeters see Santa is a smaller unit
than the meters and if you go from
centimeters to decimeters okay the
Destiny decimeters ten times larger than
a centimeter a meter is ten times larger
than a decimeter so what we have is 10 x
10 so a meter is a hundred times larger
than a centimeter or you can think that
there's a hundred centimeters that fit
into one meter okay so what we have is
we have 100 centimeters for every one
meter so you can see again the units
that we don't want our cancelling and we
just want to convert now let's see we've
got meters want to convert today so we
have minutes let's convert minutes to
hours so there's 60 minutes in one hour
minutes are cancelling numerator nanamia
we were left with hours but we want days
so we say there's 24 hours per one day
and again you can see the units are
canceling numerator denominator you may
try tit this way you say okay wait a
second you know I have to flip it over
because I want those units to cancel so
you'll know you've set it up right as
long as these are equal 24 hours is
equal to one day you're not changing the
value of the fraction you're just
changing the way that it looks you're
just changing the units okay so let's
just see we're left with meters
per day so all you have left to do is
multiply 8 x 1 x 60 x 24 and then 1 x
100 x 1 x 1 ok that's the denominator
and then divide those two and you're
gonna get the number of meters per day
meters / days so I hope you're enjoying
this video I hope you learn something go
ahead and subscribe to the channel check
out some of my past videos and I've got
some more videos like these coming so
stay tuned and I'll talk to you soon